the sounds of hymns across Ukraine
signals a new tradition
for Generations Christians in Ukraine
and Russia celebrated Christmas on
January 7th but in the latest rejection
of Moscow the Ukrainian Orthodox Church
is celebrating today
this is a significant event for the
whole of Ukraine citizens we've been
fighting for a long time to celebrate
Christmas on December 25th
but there was no Christmas reprieve from
the war the death toll has now reached
16 in Kirsten after a Russian strike a
civilian was here said the soldier the
car burned down despite the attacks
Russian President Vladimir Putin told
State media he's willing to have talks
to end the war we are ready to negotiate
with everyone involved about acceptable
Solutions but that is up to them we are
not the ones refusing to negotiate they
are Ukrainian Western allies suspect
Putin's claims are employed by time
after multiple Russian military defeats
Putin needs to come back to reality
tweeted a key advisor to Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski Russia
single-handedly attacked Ukraine and is
killing citizens
himself uses Christmas address to warn
ukrainians of the hardships
our fight will continue unabated it is
not threatened by planned or emergency
blackouts he said
[Music]
those power outages the result of
Russian strikes on Ukrainian key
interests
leaving families like Leslie azadilskias
to eat dinner by candlelight and cook
over our gas camping we know they want
to destroy all our holidays so some
holiday days for us they could be
targets for them just like it is in her
Zone the Christmas spirit still shining
throughout Ukraine Mackenzie gray Global
News
Ottawa